Katie welcome to the Dave Ramsey chef
hi mr. Ramsey I'm a little bit nervous
actually I've been listening to you
since I was 10 years old oh my goodness
how old are you now back how old are you
not 29 Wow very cool I'm holding I was
an FPU baby I love it
my question is my husband and I are 500
dollars shy of finishing baby sis curry
yay and yes I've never been in debt he
had some issues so we worked through
that okay our house needs a lot of work
so it needs probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of 50 to 60 thousand
dollars worth of work oh my goodness
it was a great deal I bet
yeah but he's going to those gung-ho
into four or five and six I'm wanting to
take the next year and really instead of
doing like a three B's they just save up
the renovation we need a new roof
cleaning their flooring we need and
let's go feed a lot of stuff how much
can you save in a year he makes eighty
thousand a year how much connectional
even a year probably perfectly thirty
really push it but you need fifty or
sixty yeah okay so what are you gonna do
this cash flow to write you don't just
get the big projects out of the way with
the 30 and then cash flow a lot of the
little stuff along the way after that
while doing four five six
okay what's your house worth today you
know spend $60,000 on $100,000 house
sections of wall we are mid Reno when we
decided to get really serious about baby
step three we're basically camping
that's what it sounds like
okay yeah definitely do baby step three
B and use that for renovation for one
year for sure
and what you need to do is lay out your
renovation projects and price them and
then pry to break them apart as separate
projects and then prioritize them okay
because you're not going to do it all at
once but you can start one
almost immediately right I mean let's
say let's say you were gonna do $30,000
in your it's $2,500 a month so in two
months you could do a $5,000 project
like February how much is that know you
ain't got in bids then you need to get
bit yeah you need to get bits if that's
number one then you just start saving
towards it but what's the number one you
might want to knock out a couple of
little things like put up a wall that
kind of stuff
is the roof leaking yeah I want it to be
fixed this calendar year then in the 30
right yeah so you're gonna get it within
12 months but you might want to knock
out a couple of the little projects
first just for quality of life if the
roof is not leaking inside the house in
other words if you got some walls that
are unfinished inside the house that
would be an example I don't care make
your bet make you listen here's what you
do start getting it start getting here
but start getting your projects make a
list of them and get bids on each
individual project not the projects as a
group each individual project and then
prioritize them I don't care you decide
when you want to do which which one do I
want knowing that I can get through one
through seven or whatever it is I don't
care in 12 months those are the ones
that I don't have to be so hardcore
about but the other ones are gonna be a
while before I get to them because I'm
going to cashflow those while starting
my baby step four is that all making
sense yeah yeah 2500 bucks a month gets
you a long way through this list and if
you're careful it might get you almost
all the way through it and by the time
I'm talking yeah so by the time I'm
talking to you next year you got a whole
different house Merry Christmas right
yeah good job
well done good job